a scandal at Harvard University to
revoke admission officers to at least 10
members of his incoming freshman class
school officials took the action after
they learned that students had exchanged
vulgar and offensive messages on
Facebook the news was first reported by
the University of student newspaper the
Harvard Crimson on Dayla is at the Ivy
League campus in Cambridge Massachusetts
with the disturbing post Don good
morning good morning the students used a
private by invitation only chat room to
exchange those memes which are typically
images that have a funny caption but
evidently the college officials found
these so offensive they wanted nothing
to do with the students that sent them
CBS News has edited the racist and
explicit contents in some of these memes
the memes some of which are too graphic
for TV made jokes about sexual assault
victims and the Holocaust and mocked
different ethnic groups one message
asked people to casually send nudes
these images were published by the tab a
new service run by college students
there were I think only fifteen or
twenty people even in the group 17 year
old Wyatt herd will be a freshman at
Harvard in the fall he did not
participate in the facebook chat group
and says members of his class alerted
university officials going to the school
you sign an honor code it is a privilege
to attend a school any school much less
Harvard you look at the content of those
and it's pretty hard to defend them in
any capacity at all according to the
Crimson the group was called Harvard
memes for horny bourgeois teens the
university revoked the admissions offers
in April nothing's private online Ivy
wise CEO Kat Cohen counsels prospective
college students about their social
media profiles it's important for
students to know that about 35 percent
of college admissions officials will
actually Google a student and look at
their online identity
Harvard's Facebook page for its incoming
class notes the college can withdraw
admission if an admitted student engages
in behavior that brings into question
his or her honesty maturity or moral
character and I think that any sane
person looking at this would question
someone
morality and judgment so it was
definitely the right thing to do
Harvard has not released the names of
any of the affected students and in fact
they put out a statement that says they
will not comment on the admission status
of any individual some forty thousand
people applied for the class of 2021
only about twenty one hundred were
admitted and of those seventeen hundred
are expected to enroll in the fall gale
very tough lesson but Harvard means for
horny boudoir teens it's probably a clue
that's not a good place to go thank you
don